et alain griset elle concerne
bridgestone puisque le groupe japonais a
annoncé la fermeture de l'usiné
bridgestone de béthune avec 8 163
emplois menacés c'est l'échec de l'état
pour conserver ce tissu industriel
tout d'abord vous savez que je suis
originaire des hautes france et donc
l'oissu dossier béthune me touche à plus
d'un titre d'abord dire que
naturellement c'est pour les salariés ce
terrible c'est pour leur famille
terrible c'est pour le territoire
terrible savez comme la région
d'ailleurs l'état a indiqué depuis
plusieurs semaines sa volonté
d'accompagner l'entreprise pour une
transformation
ma collègue agnès payan attaché a
indiqué que l'état était prêt à mettre
de l'argent pour cette entreprise se
trouve que la ligue joue pas le jeu
à mon avis tout n'est pas terminé
l'état continuera à tout faire pour
essayer de sauver l'emploi dans ce
territoire
l état continuera merci beaucoup
[Musique]